YouTube
NPC Trend Tick Tock she's the worst
take your cash check your kilo yes yes
oh thank you Samantha this is so cool
take your cat in take your mail it's
okay I'm ready gang gang oh thank you
baby this is
what the [__] dude
oh man
this is another one
oh my God this is a real person I guess
they're acting like NPCs because they
have no Talent or something I don't know
it's like it's a [__] God damn it
learn to trade you know I don't even
like sing [__] you know what I mean
Dan do a [__] protect there's people
out there that are at least awfully
singing they're bad at it but it's like
dude at least try something
you know ah [__] and you reward them you
give them roses
these [__] pervy 57 year old men just
fat [__] giving them roses and [__]
and they're just sitting there yum yum
ooh roses yum yum and it's like dude no
not yum yum and not roses
[__] learn how to
learn how to dance Nicki Minaj you know
what I do on that mic I destroyed I
destroyed These Hoes whoa a cake
oh the NPC trend
oh um
uh get the [__] hands out of
here I done told y'all that [__] don't
get blocked [__] they're doing the NPC
thing two walks on the beach
oh no
yes yes
oh Glizzy
I mean
what is honestly
I don't like to say this but what is
going on in this world
why did they do this
the best
thing about these ones are the regular
people that do it I mean that's pretty
stupid